the biggest challenge labor is less
valuable because of efficiencies with
technology and it's going to get better
and better for technology which is scary
when you think about what's gonna happen
for jobs and so how do you stay relevant
so it's great to say you need to retool
you need to stay relevant how do you
actually do it so if you want to be
treated as an on commodity act like an
on commodity no one is a commodity if
they don't want to do
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message retool yourself over
to you Tony Robbins I always tell people
the most valuable lesson I got from my
mentor Jim Rohn was I asked my father
worked two jobs
we were always broke we had no money for
food and we lived in a community we
moved to it's just I thought they were
all rich and we were on the other side
of the tracks it was a
lower-middle-class but compared to where
we lived before these people seemed rich
compared to us and I just didn't
understand it and Jim said to me Tony
it's not about the value of your soul
it's about the value of you in the
marketplace and your father's skills are
not that high well he used to take he
was underground parking attendant and he
would take people's ticket and make
change well the research now shows it's
being done at Yale's being done overseas
in England as well and they found that
40 percent of all jobs they project in
the next 10 years are going to disappear
because of technology it's gonna be
replaced by an algorithm it's gonna be
changed you know all these guys on Wall
Street you're seeing all these
algorithms take over and they're getting
rid of all these traders right it's
changing radically these in these hedge
funds there's three million truck
drivers self-driving cars are here in
the next five years they will be the
standard certainly within seven or eight
years are you gonna hire someone who can
only work eight hours a day and
sometimes gets drunk or can make a
mistake when you can buy a machine right
on the machine and be in a position
where it works 24 hours a day driving
but no one is telling these drivers this
and it's they have to retool now so
technology is the biggest challenge
labor is less valuable because of
efficiencies with technology and it's
going to get better and better for
technology which is scary when you think
about what's gonna happen for jobs so I
say to people you got to participate in
your own rescue
you've got to retool yourself the idea
of the Bernie Sanders has of providing
free education it sounds wonderful but
the education he wants to do is
Community College there are no skill
sets in Community College's today for
the most part that are gonna prepare you
for the economy or a job that's there so
what is that going to do you're just
going to waste more money more time we
need to retool ourselves the
government's not gonna do it for you
technology is coming for everybody it's
not just cashiers it's not just truck
drivers it's everybody it's you it's me
it's Tony Robbins it's everybody and the
way through is to stay relevant to
understand where the world is going
where the world currently is even right
now and staying relevant to that
audience
so Tony talked about Jim Rowan is big
into this clip and this is one of the
saddest things in the history of my
company Jim Rohn is Tony Robbins his
mentor and of all the people that we've
tried making deals with for my youtube
channel Jim Rohn or at least the estate
of Jim Rohn cuz he has passed is one of
the only people we've not been able to
make a deal with for my channel so why
is there no Jim Rohn on my YouTube
channel because we weren't able to make
a deal with his estate where everybody
else we've made arrangements with they
love that we're promoting them and
giving them exposure on this platform
and it's really sad for me because Jim
Rowan is quickly fading into existence
if you were to walk on the street 50
years ago and asked people who Jim Rohn
is he would have fairly high name
recognition now you walk down the street
you ask who Tony Robbins is people would
know who Tony Robbins is most people
don't know who Jim Rohn is Millennials
and under definitely unless you are
really astute really focused on studying
the greats you will not know who Jim
Rohn is and that's a tragedy not just
for Jim Rohn in his legacy but for the
world this is Tony Robbins his mentor
and he's gonna fade to dust because his
estate is worried about selling CDs
his estate wants to be able to sell Jim
Rohn CDs nobody's behind CDs anymore and
this is the problem you can have the
best skills in the world you have the
best knowledge in the world but if you
are not staying relevant to today's
market you will lose if it can happen to
Jim Rohn it can happen to anybody and
it's gonna happen to youtubers I'm not
attached to YouTube I want to help
entrepreneurs in whatever platform makes
the most sense right now YouTube is
crushing it's dominating is a great
alignment of what I'm great at and where
you guys are and so that's where I am
but in 10 years YouTube will either not
exist or will look completely different
than what it is right now for all the
people who complain about the YouTube
algorithm or if YouTube goes under
they're complaining they're whining
they're upset don't like this is the
world change is coming for you you need
to be able to adapt and for people like
Jake Paul who went from being a vine
star and then vine shutting down to be
able to quickly take over YouTube and
start crushing it that's the mindset you
need to constantly have so if YouTube is
still around in ten years they'll look
totally different than what it is right
now and if you want to win on YouTube
ten years from now you need to continue
to adjust and to learn and market and
get better and so how do you stay
relevant so it's great to say you need
to retool you need to stay relevant how
do you actually do it how did she know
what to pay attention to the easiest
thing right now is to use this use your
phone this will tell you where people
are paying attention and how you can
learn from that to apply it to your
business so I use an Android phone so I
use Google Play what I recommend doing
is go and look at what the apps are go
and look at all the most popular apps
and these change on a regular basis just
look at the apps and see what's up there
and see what might be relevant to your
business so if clash of clans is number
one it's a game it's not relevant to
your business great bypass it move on to
the next one but look at what's
constantly in the top charts all of them
so Google Play here is a thing called
pop charts click on top charts and see
what these are understand what these
programs are understandably are relevant
to your business or not right the number
one showing up for me right now is wish
great wish is the number one app on the
Google Play Store right now what is it
it's the top free shopping app get
fashion shoes electronics kitchen
gadgets and more at 60 to 90 percent off
if you're selling any of these things
electronics shoes fashion kitchen
gadgets and more
maybe you should at least know what wish
is maybe you should try to develop a
wish strategy what else is on here
Instagram Spotify snapchat YouTube
Facebook like this is where people are
paying attention so you need to at least
understand those platforms understand
those apps and devise a strategy to win
on those because that's where the world
is going I don't want you to turn the
dust I don't want you to end up like Jim
Rohn not because of the ego or the
personality to have an legacy but for
the world because of the great knowledge
and abilities you have to just get lost
because you're not relevant to the
current platform you need to stay
current or become a dinosaur the choice
is yours now I've got a really special
bonus clip for you but before that I
want to know question the day what has
been in the past year one of the biggest
shifts that you have made in your
business that is started to pay off
whether it's a move to Instagram or move
to YouTube what have you done in the
past year that has helped you stay more
relevant and is working I'm curious I
think it also benefit a lot of people
watching who are struggling to stay
relevant leave it down in the comments
below thank you so much believe nation
thank you for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of vinspresso
and enjoy the bonus clip
expresso give me go
most of the people who were teaching
right now who are listening to this
thing would not hire themselves that if
you had to pick someone in the world to
do it the thing that you do you'd find
someone better than you so we've changed
the stakes and we have to be really
clear about that it used to be if you
went to Rhode Island School of Design
and you got through it you had this huge
head start on people that starts are
gone yes so when you think about it you
know when when someone says I'm a
freelancer and my primary asset is my
relationship with my clients well if I
went and asked your clients which of all
the freelancers you've worked with is
off-the-charts with the relationship
would they actually pick you this person
right that when someone says I'm able to
use light in color to create photographs
to create an indelible image in people's
heads well if I talk to the people
who've seen it are you really off the
charts so what I'm saying is yes this
institution is crumbling but that puts a
huge onus on people to be honest with
themselves about the craft that you're
not gonna get away with the craft being
what it used to be just because we could
find you and you know I gave a talk two
weeks ago to the people who make all the
imprinted items in the country like pens
and the water bottles things like the
huge industry there's 50 thousand a
hundred thousand people who do this for
a living
ninety percent of them have a big thick
catalogue they'll have the same
catalogue and the same price list and
you go to them and they say yeah I have
these water bottles which one do you
want that used to be a really important
value add because there was no internet
but now there's the internet sort by
price I'll take this water bottle I'm
done ten percent of the people actually
engage with you help you find it that
you never would have thought of deliver
the thing that's off the charts are
taking huge emotional risks as they do
their work the other ninety percent are
sitting there thinking and they're in
the ten percent they're not they just
have a catalog so sometimes people throw
things at me when I'm on stage because
my argument is I didn't wish for the
world to change but it did now that the
world has changed don't get frustrated
because people are doing exactly what
you do shopping around sorting by price
buying commodities because that's what
we do when we're given the choice so if
you want to be treated as an on
commodity act like an on commodity no
one is a commodity if they don't want to
be if you tell yourself a story long
enough you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like I have Tulsa
what a wail out of handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 2:54 confidence or every
single day for two hundred fifty four
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and five minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access